[Music]
in ancient drug news submitted by Igor
the champ
a thousand-year-old drug pouch reveals
evidence of ancient psychedelic use
doubt that dang it down that looks like
out how all the forefathers did
marijuana and [ __ ] and coke or DMT you
mentioned that's like the [ __ ] I think
that's what's poppin right now I know
it's good at Joe Rogan man
coke coke is supposed to similar to like
I mean I'm crazy thing is done it's like
I've done is we've you think it's
similar to that it's like no they said
similar day hey Josh what's the matter
be chicken I wanna see God me too I
wanna meet the aliens automate the clock
working I've only had a chance to see
them twice in my dreams you should all
get together I'm so [ __ ] down that's
one way there's like a [ __ ] smoke
smoke toad toad lubricant are you can
Lake a [ __ ] frog I will damn I've
been licking eyes this whole time
thinking that was gonna give me DMT well
we got a look at homeless guys ass
oh no I'm kind of kids kind of scared
it's our last like 10 minutes right like
it's pretty short trip minutes and
there's no one that lasts 4 to 5 hours
ayahuasca is that one
I want to do a universal candle on the
one with the branding is you get shot
out of a universal cannon that's the
soil
yeah the clockwork elves dude I'm into
this [ __ ] I'm so scared no I'm dead
serious I want to do what no you're not
really do I really do not a bit it's
such a bit no no I swear I really do
want to do no no looks like marijuana I
don't mind because I get too detached
and [ __ ] because you're still in your
body this is a panel you go to another
[ __ ] university no then why would you
just go hardcore Oh actually I watch
Trainspotting does that count
[Laughter]
that was come to using do dear and I
watch my Mentos in the same day I was so
[ __ ] up I couldn't he reduced
dude I didn't do anything weed though
for that I just want that's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] stoner behavior though so they
recently discovered a 1000 year old
pouch in southwestern Bolivia and it
revealed traces of several psychic
psychoactive compounds oh yeah those
fools did hella psychedelics yeah so
they're sane the native South Americans
but they're saying that the stuff that
they found in this pouch it wasn't even
any word mere like made of to that area
but they were saying that this was a
sign of like aliens either no dude I
like the jump out of it cool committed
good for you man this indicated either
the presence of elaborate exchange
networks or the fact that this
individual was across diverse
environments to get these special plants
and so these plants they had like damn
tea was part of it this other what is it
okay so it was meta metabolic metabolic
metabolic no not follow it cabal a metal
let's have a light metabolite trace
remains of what I just says McDonald's
nobody knows maybe three people know it
was cocaine the one that I tried to
pronounce right now and then there it's
basically cocaine the active ingredient
in cocaine yeah what is this boo 14
beautiful teen beautiful tonight which
is a psychedelic snuff and then psilocin
which is a psycho a crew yeah it's a
mushroom yes and then also there was
Harmon Harmon Harmon and DMT mmm yeah so
that that was the iOS quite the plethora
this guy was a freaking ancient bomb so
they're dating this ancient crackhead
right good and arrow of some sort like a
witch yeah
I'd like to think he was a downtown LA
homeless man that time traveled yes so
they're saying that this is dated
sometime between 900 and 1100
they don't call it BC anymore I think oh
really they changed it to BCE and BCE
and [ __ ] like that all the same time
they just changed it right there
whatever state to see collector's
edition what the hell see
so it means Common Era or Christian era
Oh same thing way more confusing now
thanks a lot so it's like a D and C well
I kind of liked it better before Christ
right that's what BC was well the time
was like before Christ after death or
some [ __ ] like that right i know domme
me and about me now they're calling it
BCE before Common Era and BC before
Christ that they mean the same thing
okay cool I like that and then see E is
Common Era and that's the same thing as
a be cool I like that way more than BC
and waiting oh no no Anna Domini yeah
with that god I'm smartest [ __ ] dude
holy [ __ ] am i smart oh my god you
should just leave the room you're not I
think I just won I won the video see you
guys later
why did the world stop doing drugs
that's the pooch dude they found a
[ __ ] iPad look at that shit's iPad
there's a vape pen did yes some of these
things were like first nothing dude
what's that right there
I don't know that looks like an iPad
dude that's it does you know chopsticks
for the ancient Panda Express nobody
what is yeah so they put the powder in
there and they could put it at one nose
and go oh ever since I watched ancient
aliens I've been waiting for a news
article one day were they like they
found a [ __ ] iPad in ancient Sumeria
that dates back a thousand years and I'm
like there you go the crazy guy with the
hair was [ __ ] right
or it could be time for what I didn't
think of that [ __ ] way smarter this
ancient civilization already hit that
peak and then something happened and at
the reset and we were reduced to cavemen
they destroy themselves
mmm-hmm either that or a comet came down
and crashing in there was a worldwide
catalyst
there's a lot of theories like totally
we you were telling me that you're
listening to a podcast that talked about
this stuff yeah tell me about his name
is Graham Hancock yeah oh I'm Joe Rogan
I heard no one yes tell me about it
there's a theory and I think we spoke
about it before here but just to briefly
explain it is he thinks that there has
human history is actually longer than
what modern archaeology says it is so I
think right now the we date back to
5,000 or 10,000 years ago that's how
long human history is but what he thinks
is it could be 40 to 50 thousand years
but there's this theory called the
Clovis theory which is the idea of
Asians came from the bang straight and
then became Native Americans and and
stuff like that right but what he's
saying is like there's evidence that
prior to that whole Clovis theory
there's been human-like inhabitants in
in America but that can't be disputed
because they're saying like that's
something that mainstream science goes
that's just not disputable you can't do
it even if there's evidence coming out
saying like they're they're you know
pointing to there was humans existing
here long time ago and then also
basically they say that there's a huge
there's a civilization that was super
advanced that built the pyramids that
built all this [ __ ] but then there was
like a comet that came or something and
then there's evidence of it in Greenland
or something like that and then a big
flood happened where a lot of cultures
worldwide think there was a big flood
right because it went palm and then the
Moses party yeah a huge can happen and
then it reduced people to kind of
hunter-gatherers and then they had to
rebuild society means the part of the
dmt like like in the Amazon forest how
like they found the strain and then like
they explained like what kind of happens
life after death and then it's like
different cultures from all over the
world experience the exact same thing
that's what I like about it and
different people from all over the world
experience the same [ __ ] so what is that
experience so all the people are like
the ancient peoples of the five or five
thousand years going Egyptians or South
Americans if there's no direct contact
a really sophisticated coincidence
because everyone that has done
psychedelics they they said that once
you die you go straight to the bottom of
Orion's belt from there you shoot to the
Milky Way galaxy where you go through a
bunch of trials and tribulations - like
I guess get your final judgment and
what's crazy is all of these cultures
came up with the same exact very
detailed post life journey on their own
unless they communicated back then but
there is no evidence that any
communicated back then so the theory is
there was a there was a one civilization
that we can all trace back to roots - so
that civilization is like the starter of
that theory and then it kind of spread
all over the world but there's another
one where they're interconnected through
psychedelics and they're able to
communicate through yeah but I feel like
that's not necessarily with each other
but with whatever the collective Commons
up your additional dimension grandman
call you talks about a lot of it and
even that whole like Orion's belt thing
yeah cuz he's a I don't know if he's
like an anthropologist or like or
archaeology when they write this stuff
down
yeah he has a book hasn't multiple did
they write this how did this information
like how'd they find out about it
motivations escalate so he like a
journalist I think he was a hotel
manager but he is big especially within
pseudo scientific theories involving
ancient civilization stone monument so
he's largely shunned by the scientific
in here for sure
yeah yeah and he's so indeed so he talks
about why they do that and it's very
interesting stuff I was watching a
little bit of ancient aliens finally and
then they're talking about how crazy it
is that these pyramids all over the
world are on the same time popped up and
it's so similar and like how did that I
can't get a piece of paper between the
cracks TIFF you can't even fit a piece
of paper between the cracks that had to
be some sort of alien invention that
created that that pushed those tablets -
I love aliens it's [ __ ] foolish it is
so funny it's like dope to dream you
know dude I've never watched something
that bends
what it wants it to be harder than an
alien see I'm saying yeah like don't
take anything like how the [ __ ] did they
get boats back then dude only ancient
aliens could have given them and the
cat's like you can't make something
float it's impossible you can't do it
he's like they had to be shown how to do
this [ __ ] by ancient nail it's so
[ __ ] funny dude I love how did they
get bread and rice it's like I can't
even get bread right right now he's like
they got bread to rise the ancient [ __ ]
at Egypt it's impossible you can't Lily
can't do it the common cold as a way for
it like aliens to control us or some
[ __ ] he's like look at this ancient cave
painting and tell me that's not a
[ __ ] office chair and you're like
he's got little wheels I mean since
these are all theories like even the
Graham Hancock it's a theory and it's
all possible because there's nothing
really going against it so you take
evidence and then you extrapolate
extrapolate rather that's what ancient
aliens is so well as they extrapolate
the [ __ ] out of a little thing and they
get creative so funny butting in in
Graham Hancock's case though it's not
that much of a stretch yes yes no no
it's much more close to the it's more
ground evidence yeah there's just some
[ __ ] with the psychedelics and things
like that yeah that that that one's
gonna be a little bit more yeah cuz how
do you prove that right they put ancient
wears a jailings is like look at this
cape painting and tell me that's not
Michael J Fox and you're like what they
do like we predicted Michael J Fox how
could they have done that they had a
convention in Pasadena and and you gotta
watch this man the newest season of
ancient aliens it's still going on yeah
yeah they're dope it helps me sleep man
that's what you're trying to I'm telling
you dude okay
they really ring the [ __ ] towel out
in the show but now they're bringing
like a whole community together and some
movements like Flat Earth yeah there's
an abduction episode it's [ __ ] dull
oh I got a feel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]